if you've ever thought about running
your own business but for whatever
reason we're too afraid to take the jump
you owe it to yourself to at least
investigate it at least look into it
because otherwise you could be making
one of the biggest mistakes of your life
and missing out on a huge opportunity hi
I'm Evan Carmichael your friend in all
things entrepreneurship and I want to
tell you a little bit of a story of how
I got started when I was really young I
didn't have any role models to look up
to to say I want to be like you I want
to be an entrepreneur everybody in my
family had traditional corporate jobs
and that's what I wanted to be growing
up I had my own little ventures you know
when you're really young I sold baseball
cards I joined you in achievement we
create our own little you know company
programs and sold products but when I
graduated high school when they asked me
what did you want to be in ten years
where do you see yourself I wrote down
that would be a VP at some bank how
boring is that and it wasn't until
University where I connected with two of
my friends who had a business and they
invited me to join that I really
considered entrepreneurship as a career
path and I wonder what would have
happened if I didn't talk to those two
friends what would have happened to me
what I have joined the banking ranks be
on my career path because once you get
started it's really hard to jump off and
do your own thing afterwards the further
along you are the more difficult it is
to jump and want to do your own thing
you may want to do it but it's a lot
scarier you have more responsibilities
you have more of a track record or
rebuilt up at your company
and I really am grateful that they asked
me to join their business and i
discovered this world of
entrepreneurship because i didn't have a
huge exposure to it before and I'm so
happy that I didn't go join the
corporate ranks I can't imagine what my
life would look like if I did and so for
you if you've ever thought about
entrepreneurship if you're trying to
figure out what you want to do with your
life at least explore it
entrepreneurship isn't for everybody
it's hard it's going to be one of the
hardest things you ever do in your life
you know it's not easy for sure there's
a lot of benefits but there's a lot of
cons to it too but at least educate
yourself read some books watch some
videos go meet entrepreneurs and what
they're up to and see if that's a
lifestyle that you want and if you are
already an entrepreneur take some
responsibility and teach other people
about it expose them to the world of
business because we don't learn enough
about it in our schools and the
university when we're trained to go get
jobs and you can't blame other people
for that you know you have to take your
own personal responsibility take
accountability if you're interested in
learning about it go learn about it if
you are an entrepreneur and you think it
was the best decision you ever made in
your life teach other people about it
let them know what you're up to expose
them to that world you can help make a
difference in their lives as well thank
you for watching this video if you guys
enjoyed it please give it a thumbs up
below I always seen I love seeing them
come in and if you have a comment I'd
love to hear what you have to think I'd
love to hear your story or if you have a
question feel free leaving a comment
section below I always read those and
again